let's move on to Game of Thrones last
Sunday was the most-watched episode of
the series ever over 10 million viewers
watched it live in ET on lines Lee Ann
Aguilera was with Jamie Lannister who
also goes by his a real life name
sometimes Nikolaj coster-waldau and they
talked about his character his new
brother Lee blessing who would you say
is the father you Jamie is going to be a
father again I know it's beautiful
it's so cool I can't wait for the next
episode because he's decorating the
nursery do you think that there was any
way that Cersei could be lying about
this well I mean clearly I mean it's not
like you go no she would never lie I
mean she actually seems happy for the
first time in three seasons Jamie
believes I think Jamie believes her he's
not exactly convincing us but with only
two episodes left in the season fans may
have to wait until the eighth and final
season to find out if the pregnancy is
real never betray me again loyalty is
also the underlying theme of Nikolai's
new thriller shot-caller and your rules
and we've got the gangs rules and
there's matter
the 47 year old is nearly unrecognizable
playing a prison gangster but fans were
quick to notice the film's movie poster
looks almost identical to the 2013 movie
snitch starring the rock now I can
finally tell you the truth I have been
Dwayne the rock Johnson's body double
for the last 10 years it's true yeah I
work out 5 hours every day and you know
this is how you get to this point all
jokes aside Nikolai did have to bulk up
for the role putting on 20 pounds of
muscle he also grew a beard and sat
through 4 hours of makeup each day to
get those tattoos would your family
think when you were like in the full
game I liked it yeah yeah I think it was
Lucy it was a very safe way of hanging
out with him the bad boy the Danish star
has been married for almost 20 years and
has two teenage daughters he says his
family still hasn't seen an episode of
Thrones but was a movie a cool years ago
it did where and my daughter watched it
was called the other woman was kind of
playing this guy who was making out with
all of them and and they couldn't even
get through the whole film they just
thought it was disgusting